welcome back we're on problem number six
problem number six on page six seventy
if the average of six 6 12 16 and X the
average is equal to X what is the value
of x so if I were to average all these
numbers i get x so how do i average i
add them up i add up the numbers and i
divide by the number of numbers there
are so there's one two three four five
numbers i / that and they're saying that
this average is going to equal x so
let's multiply both sides by 5 and I get
6 plus 6 plus 12 plus 16 plus X is equal
to 20 Oh what so I my brain is
malfunctioning the average is equal to X
right so i have to multiply both sides
by 5 and so i get going to get x anyway
so i multiply both sides by 5 i get 5x
right this is the average and they say
the average is equal to X multiply both
sides by 5 you get rid of the 5 in the
denominator here you get 5x on the
right-hand side now what's this some 6
plus 6 is 12 12 plus 12 is 24 24 plus 16
is 40 so we get 40 plus X is equal to 5x
subtract X from both sides for t is
equal to 4x divide both sides by 4 you
get x is equal to 10 and that is choice
D next problem
let me draw this triangle let me try my
best to draw the triangle looks
something like that and then there is an
altitude right here just drop straight
down and then they tell us that this is
a 90 or do they tell us my cousin you
who used my book drew over it so i'm not
sure but i think i'm pretty sure they
tell us that this is a 90-degree angle
so the figure above what is the value of
Z so they say this is this is Z this is
why this is 2 y and this is 40 degrees
so what is Z so we know this is a 90
degree angle and we know that Z plus y
plus 90 is equal to 180 so if we know
what Y is we could figure out Z then how
can we figure out why well we know that
too why if we look at this right-hand
triangle we know that 2y plus 40 plus 90
plus 90 is equal to is equal to 180
right so 2y plus 130 is equal to 180 2y
is equal to 50 degrees y is equal to 25
25 degrees so this is 25 degrees I
really wish I could read this problem
I'm pretty sure they drew in a little
perpendicular thing anyway we might have
been able to address any if they didn't
but if y is 25 then we know that Z + 25
+ 90 is equal to 180 z+ 1 15 is equal to
180 z is equal to subtract 1 15 from
both sides what's a t minus 15 it's 65
the choice is C
next problem problem number eight
problem number eight a computer program
randomly selects a positive two digit
integer if the integer selected it is
odd twice that integer is printed so odd
it prints two times integer if the
integer is even the integer itself is
printed so integer I'm sorry if it's
even it just prints the integer so if
it's an odd in your x two it's actually
going to print an even integer no matter
what if the integer printed is 26 which
of the following could have been the
integer selected so all we see is 26 we
just see 26 so the 26 could have been
generated one of two ways it could have
been generated by an even number that
was just kept the same well if it was an
even number that was kept the same when
you got 26 then we know that the number
is 26 the orig the number that generated
was 26 the other possibility is it could
have been an odd number that was doubled
right if it was an odd number that was
doubled that means 2 times the odd
number two times the odd number is equal
to 26 so that means that the number
would have to be 13 right 13 times odd
is sorry two times odd these are the two
situations two times odd is going to be
equal to 26 in which case odd is equal
to 13 or one times even is going to be
equal to 26 in which case even equals 26
so the number generator could have been
26 or it could have been 13 and those
are choices one and two and that's C
next problem problem number 9
problem 9 they give you a choice 52 in
that last problem just to confuse you to
actually end up doubling the 26 but we
know that the odd number was doubled to
get 26 so the number generated would
have been 13 problem number 9 how many
seconds are there in EM minutes and as
seconds em minutes and s seconds and
minutes and s seconds well how many
seconds are there per minute what we can
write this as let's write let's write
this expression as M minutes plus s
seconds right well what does m equal in
terms of seconds or how many how many
seconds are there per minute well we
know that there are 60 seconds per m
right or we could say we could say that
that 60 seconds is equal to 1 M right so
if there's 60 seconds in 1m how many I'm
actually I'm confusing the issue let me
write it this way M minutes right
there's M minutes how many how many
seconds are there per minute so there
are let me start over because I think i
confuse you a little bit so i'm going to
write actually let me write it without
M&S that's what's confusing me as well
let's say I have X minutes + @ + y
seconds plus y seconds and I want to
convert it all in two seconds well we
know that there are 60 seconds per
minute right so if we want to convert a
minute two seconds we write X minutes
times x 60 seconds per minute plus y
seconds and so the minutes will cancel
out and so you're left with 60 times X
and this is something that you'll learn
in physical class is that you can treat
units just
you would treat variables and they'll
cancel out so early so you get 60 x mid
60 X right the minutes have canceled out
let me switch colors you'll get 60 times
X seconds plus y seconds so your total
number of seconds is 60 x + y + in the
problem though in minutes they didn't
say aunt they didn't say X they said M
so X is M and then why is s why is that
so 60 m 60 m sorry 60 M plus s so that's
choice a and this might have been a
little confusing let me let me do it a
simpler way or maybe a more intuitive
way to for you if there's m minutes how
many seconds are in EM minutes how many
seconds in EM minutes think about it if
there's if I'm talking about two minutes
there are 60 seconds per minute so if I
said two minutes two minutes i would
multiply two times 60 and i would get to
120 seconds if it was five minutes i
would multiply 5 x 60 and get to 300
seconds so if i have em minutes i'll
multiply 60 times m to get 60 m seconds
60 m seconds and of course they said m
minutes plus s seconds so now i have 60
m seconds plus these s seconds so my
total number of seconds is 60 m plus s
this is a more intuitive way maybe you
know you should always try out numbers
and hopefully it'll make a little bit
more sense the way I did it previously
is how you would do it in physics class
where you would actually cancel out the
units and make sure you're doing it the
right way see in the next video